mark meredith live at the white house
with the very latest on that in the
aftermath of seeing the president come
out on the balcony
and give a uh rousing 18-minute speech
uh to
some of his supporters there hi eric
president trump he seemed like he was
thrilled to be back out there speaking
with supporters this was an event that
was billed as something geared towards
law enforcement supporters and while he
did have a lot of different topics in
his speech
the president also took a few moments to
address his personal battle with
coronavirus
first of all i'm feeling great i don't
know about you how is everyone feeling
good on behalf of myself and the first
lady
it just has been really an incredible
outpouring and
we're starting very very big with our
rallies and with our everything because
we cannot
allow our country to become
a socialist nation the president kept
his distance from the crowd by speaking
from a balcony at the white house most
of the supporters gathered were wearing
masks as far as we could tell
but there really was little to no social
distancing out there and while this was
billed as an official white house event
it sure felt like a campaign speech with
the president
having plenty to say not only about
democrats in the polls but also his
chances come november
we have had more enthusiasm right now
right now
this year than we had four years ago by
a factor of three times
i just wanna thank you and get out and
vote
we're gonna make this bigger than even
four years ago it's more important this
is the most important election we've
ever had
the white house schedule can change
pretty much day to day but we do have an
idea of where the president is going to
restart his campaigning and that
includes in florida on monday
a rally outside of orlando and sanford
then they also have those events that
you guys were just talking about
in pennsylvania and iowa i wouldn't be
shocked to see another event added on
the schedule because the debate that was
supposed to happen in miami eric
that's been cancelled so we know that
the third presidential bait or what will
really be the second one
is now gonna happen later no debate this
week so instead the president's gonna
have plenty of time to go out and
campaign
eric and that'll do mark thanks so much
you better